[Music]
hello there watching the press preview a
first look then at what is on the front
pages time to see what's making the
headlines we're the columnist
broadcaster carol malone and the
political editor of the liverpool echo
liam thorpe welcome to both of you so
let's start with the front pages the
metro welcomes the news of cousins's
imprisonment declaring take him down and
never let him out the telegraph quotes
metropolitan police commissioner dame
cressida dick saying a precious bond of
trust has been damaged
the eye carries or carries calls rather
for dame cressida's resignation
the mirror also looks at calls for her
to quit their headline never again
the guardian also pictures dame cressida
but focuses on cousins life sentence
with a front that reads shaming of the
met killer officer given full life term
and the northern echo presents images of
each of the 80 women allegedly killed at
the hands of a man since sarah was
murdered in march the paper asks when
will this end
well karen carol malone and liam thorpe
are here not surprising that this case
carol is dominating uh the metro on the
fact of the sentencing that whole life
term uh your reflections on the
sentencing today
you know this is this is the most severe
sentence ever handed down
to a serving police officer and it is
the met police's greatest shame
and and it's interesting that you have
cressida dick out there apologizing
today saying i'm sorry and committing
herself to woman's safety when it is it
was on her watch that this terrible
murder happened there was there are so
many questions she has to answer in fact
i don't think she should actually be
allowed to answer anything because we
know what happened there's been a cat
there's been a catalogue of catastrophes
on this woman's watch we know what the
word john paul de menaces operation
midland you know
i'm and this this is her greatest shame
and she can't just stand out there and
say i'm sorry that is not good enough
for the parents of sarah everard you
know i was watching that family and i
watched them all through the court case
the courage it's taken them to do what
they have done the courage it took for
them to face down this man in court and
to say to him
look at me look at us so you can see
what you've done
i'm in awe of those people and their
lives are all ruined but this someone
has to take responsibility for what
happened and it should be crescent a
dick and if she clings on after this it
would be to her eternal shape every
newspaper is calling for her to resign
for very very good reasons well tom
windsor chief inspector of constabulary
is not he says she is behaving with
distinction in her role as chief
constable of the met
that she is not culpable for these
crimes are you surprised then liam that
uh politicians like harriet harman
notably for example has so firmly nailed
her colors to the mast on this story
no i'm not surprised to see that we've
seen cross-party calls from harriet
harman from caroline knox from from
other extremely uh influential
politicians
what we haven't seen action from is is
pretty patel obviously who is who has
stood by and only recently um rewarded
christopher dick with a new two-year
contract as carol says this isn't you
know this isn't the first time there
have been calls for her to resign it
isn't the first time in the last few
months that they've been called we saw
obviously strong calls around the
handling of the vigil and that was held
after sarah everyone's death we've also
seen calls um because of the handling of
the daniel morgan murder case where
where the met was described as
institutionally corrupt you know the
book has to stop at the top and if if
people are going to see the change that
they need to see which they desperately
need to see within the metropolitan
police force how can it be led by the
person that has been found so often
leading this uh
leading on the in these issues i think
it's her position is completely
untenable and it's remarkable that the
home secretary is standing by her how
can people have faith in the police
force when she remains in post the
problem is just
what can i just carol let's ask you one
question about that before before you
continue the problem with focusing on
just one person and focusing on
somebody's resignation as you forget all
the other things that could be improved
that talk about vetting and re-vetting
when you move forces for example is one
of the things that has come up in the in
the way in cousin's case so if you just
go oh somebody needs to resign you don't
go in depth about all the things that
might actually make improvements so
somebody like wayne cousins could have
been identified earlier
cressida dick had her chance to change
the med police after the the vip child
abuse scandal she didn't change it then
but i think what is incredibly important
and she pointed this out today she said
people have lost trust in the police
most importantly women have lost trust
in the police at a time when the met
police force is being run by a woman
that cannot be the case she says she's
committing herself to women's safety she
hasn't we see the evidence of this you
know as liam says you know the reason
she gets the big box is because she's at
the top she has to take responsibility
she has to be accountable for what
happens in her force and we know all the
red flags that what that were put up
about this guy cousins you know how did
he get through the vetting process at
the met police when he was called mr
rapist in another police force and yet
he was put in a position where he was
put at the very heart of the
establishment with a gun to try to
protect parliamentarians it is lunacy
for that alone she should be said the
guardian shaming of the met killer
officer given a full life term picturing
there obviously dame cressida a great
long statement written statement issued
by the metropolitan police tonight
issuing some of the things that they
have changed and the things they want to
do for example they've established a
specialist predatory offender unit which
was done last november before sarah
everard was murdered and that has so far
arrested more than 2 000 suspects for
domestic abuse sex offenses and for
child abuse the met growing deploying
650 new officers they'll go to busy
public places where women and girls feel
more vulnerable they'll take more
seriously indecent exposure which was
one of the other elements that could be
pointed at wayne cousins um you know
perhaps she she is changing things and
if a woman can't do it liam um
why should she not be given the
opportunity to try
i think as carol says she's had
numerous opportunities before and i
think it's about trust she said today
you know that a sacred bond of trust has
been broken and i think that that bond
has been broken with her at the helm and
i think for people and as cows are
particularly women to recover that trust
in the police she has to go and it has
to be a new room a new leader who brings
in these changes you know sweeping
sweeping changes a total inquiry needs
to be held and she cannot be at the helm
when this happens
you're right in what you say anna that
it's
you know we shouldn't focus entirely on
one person because there are systemic
failings here but it is symbolic and it
and it needs to be led by somebody else
why was he free has obviously been the
question for many because of these
indecent exposure claims uh the nickname
of
the rapist
the knowledge perhaps about his um
extreme his interest in extreme
pornography but these are sort of these
are these are also systemic societal
issues are they not you cannot focus on
the fact that he happened to be a police
officer which makes the crime doubly bad
these were obviously that were known by
his colleagues it's interesting there's
a lady tonight a former
i think she's the chief superintendent
and a lady called pam sadhu she says
that when she was at the met it was it
was 10 women were too scared to report
men for any kind of abuse because she
said basically
the forces is misogynistic and she said
she reported something that had happened
to her and she was vilified for it and
she's based she too was saying president
dick must go because all of these things
have been happening on her watch
yes and she said that one day she'll
know she'll have to call on some of
those those men that she might have
reported on and that was that was the
danger
colleague protection is certainly
something that sir tom windsor talked
about today um about the difficulty of
highlighting actions that need to be
raised uh in something like the police
force um you know is it old-fashioned
what's the basis what's the underlying
issues here liam do you think
well that's what um what a few of these
former officers including palm sandy
have said are kind of a kind of boys
club where people close ranks and and
and
it's been very hard for people to report
issues i think there is a cultural issue
clearly within the met um and and that's
why again just to repeat what i said
earlier you know
to to deal with these cultural issues
you kind of have to deal with this from
the top down and and and crested has
presided over these issues um so you
have to start there but you're right a
much more wide-ranging issue is needed i
mean i think obviously we're all
extremely shocked by this case and and
it's incredibly chilling hearing the
details about how he used his position
as a police officer we've seen some
officers today sort of rather bizarrely
saying they don't they don't see him as
a police officer well the fact is he he
is and he certainly was when he when he
abducted sarah he was a police officer
and he used his power in his position
and that's that's one of the most
chilling aspects of this and why
ultimately massive change within the
force needs to happen well in this great
long statement from the met they even
advise people uh to ask searching
questions of officer officers when
they're arrested where are your
colleagues where have you come from why
are you here exactly why are you
stopping or talking to me you know
trying to seek some independent
verification of what they say and this
can be complicated arresting people if
everyone sticks to this list of
questions certainly
the mirror asking
never again
again repeating some of the the points
you're both making demands for an
overhaul of justice system and policing
to protect women urgent action is vital
to make the streets safe which takes us
to the northern echo as well when will
this end the 80 women um who have
allegedly been killed at the hands of
men since the tragic murder of sarah
everard six months ago which takes me
back to that societal issue and raised
by things like everyone's invited the
students being asked
to to tell of their tales um
what what does need to change more
broadly in terms of access to
pornography or social media attitudes to
women you know things people watch or
see or talk about carol i mean we've
talked about this for years haven't we
yeah we have and you know the echo from
page where it says you know 80 women
killed by
men women are mostly killed by men and
and this this is this is nothing new but
what is new in in this particular murder
is that it was committed by someone who
was in a position of trust you know i
was reading the details of how he got
her into that car and and
i don't think even
you know i don't see that another young
woman on another night somewhere if she
is approached by a police officer
wouldn't get into a police car because
how do you say no to someone in the
uniform to someone who's got a truncheon
in his pocket to someone who can hurt
you who was who was an officer of the
law
you know we can't presume that every
police officer is a rapist but you know
are we gonna have to do that from now on
and i think that is the problem you know
this this institution the police force
and the reason he has been sent down for
for the rest of his life is that we're
supposed to be able to have absolute
trust in the police and that has been
broken with this in the most
catastrophic way and i don't think any
changes quest that a dick can make
is going to change that anytime soon and
and none of this is you know whatever
quest that a dick says today or tomorrow
or next week it's not going to help the
family of sarah everard you know they
can't unhear what they heard in court
they can't unsee the evidence that they
saw they can never forget the brutality
you know
cousins took more than sarah's life that
day he took that entire families you
know they will carry on living they will
put one foot in front of the other every
day but that's not living their lives
will never be the same this man is
responsible for that this man who's in a
position of responsibility and it's
shameful and that's why crested
addiction resign yes they can't
unimagine her final hours which is uh
you know the torture of living with a
case like this isn't it um in terms of
uh men's attitude to all of this do men
look to themselves we've had high
profile cases you know celebrities the r
kelly case harvey weinstein that started
that the whole business uh
of of of what how men behaves
specifically men in power i guess as
well do do men or will men stop and
think a bit more about it do you think
um
liam is it you know is is that the
change will that change come
i think that absolutely has to happen i
think i mean obviously you're putting
out the northern echo front page which
is extremely powerful front page um you
know the sarah everard case has shocked
us all deeply and there are particularly
shocking elements in regarding the fact
that um that that he was of course a
police officer but you know as the
northern echo point out 80 women
allegedly killed in in the time since
sarah fraud was killed we've had the
shocking cases of sabine and nessa and
of course there's a charge now in that
case um
other other horrendous cases like the
nicole the sisters in london you know
this is a
a terrible time um for
for these cases and i think we you know
people need to look
uh towards that towards themselves we've
seen people in positions of power you
mentioned r kelly harvey weinstein um
but as kyle says the particularly
chilling aspect again about this case is
that he was a police officer we have
this kind of you know this innate sense
of of trust when somebody uh in a
uniform comes near us we we we think oh
well they're in it for the right reasons
and i think it will have shaken that
trust in so many people it's
it's it's it's a horrific case and and
just to echo what carol says i think
that the family of sarah everard have
acted with such dignity throughout this
process in under the most trying
circumstances um and the dignified thing
for for crested dickwood to do would be
to leave her role and allow someone else
to come and try and try and start to
restore that trust in the police
okay well you've uh you both come from
the same uh playbook there don't you on
that subject certainly uh lost more
still to come liam carroll for the
moment thank you uh next though how much
blame should the government take for the
fuel crisis we'll discuss that
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
please subscribe
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
there are hundreds of these turbines but
thousands more across gansu
that's what's left of the north tunnel
uh where the north koreans exploded five
nuclear warheads
[Music]
and this is a show of strength at a time
when china is more fragile than it has
been at any time in recent years
[Music]
from that explosion you can see it
littered along all the way we take you
to the heart of the stories that shape
our world
the train station the airport they're
both closed we're not sure about the
roads we've seen reports that they are
being blocked by police so we're going
to try and find a way
after out days stranded here this is
deliverance we help you understand the
world with us
tom cheshire sky news beijing
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now carol malone
and liam thought welcome back to both of
you um front page of the telegraph uh
pointing out that we're being told this
fuel crisis is over despite the fact
that we know that many places still
don't have fuel and the queues are still
big liam called gaslighting apparently
in this article
yes i mean i'm always a fan of a pun and
i don't know if they meant it like that
but yeah gaslighting i think you know
the government
this government particularly we are used
to them telling those things and us
having to sort of double back and think
is that true but we don't even need to
in this case because we can see it right
in front of us the queues continue there
are i think the telegraph says there
were um
20 27 of petrol stations were out of
fuel yesterday and yet we've got
ministers whether it's quasiquation
grant chaps or boris johnson telling us
that things are stabilizing well people
don't just aren't just going to believe
what they say they can go out and try
and buy fuel themselves they can look on
the forecourt and and listen more
importantly to industry leaders who are
saying that there's still a big crisis
here um you know generally if things are
stabilizing you don't call on the army
to to come and drive trucks so it's i
think it is a bit of gaslighting it's
obviously trying to manage the message
and desperately trying to
not look weak at a time when the country
is in complete and utter chaos so i'm
not surprised to see um the government
telling
mistrudes on this and i think industry
leaders are pretty angry about it as
well as you can see in that story yeah
they said around uh 50 had petrol and
diesel at some point today didn't they
but i think it's geographically
geographically it's not evenly spread as
part of the problem isn't it uh in the
meantime though donecraft new in his
role obviously the headline he ends up
with today pay offenders to drive hgvs
in a fuel crisis suggest rob which is
not great on the on the wayne cousins
day is it carol
uh i mean i just think it's the most
ludicrous suggestion he makes it sound
like driving an htv is an easy job i
would think every hgv driver in the
country would be serious at the
suggestion that an offender can just
jump into the cabin and off he goes it's
it's a highly skilled job you need
training you need to be good at it
you've seen how these guys drive the
little canon little holes and alleyways
the back end do with these huge trucks
it's not an easy thing and i'm not
entirely sure offenders should be doing
in charge of a a 10-ton truck i don't
think that should be the case but you
know read the supplies it's interesting
isn't it
you're talking about the goblin gas
lighting i think there's a bit i think
there is trickery in there but i think
it's there
they're trying to say that it's it's
under control because they hope that
will
kid the public into believing it is and
therefore not panic by because it was it
was a week ago when we were told and
there'd been a leak by the former
haulage boss saying it was going to be
these shortages and everybody run out
and started to buy petrol you know we
have the same amount of hg v drivers
today as we had a week and a half ago
and there was no petrol problem a week
and a half ago and there still is no
it's a confected crisis and caused by
all of us
without exception running out to try and
fill our tanks because we're scared
we're not going to be able to go
anywhere do our jobs
we're running out of time i do apologize
and uh just to repeat the dominic rob
story is community sentences uh for
those people he suggested uh but the end
justifies the means i suppose in terms
of trying to calm us down according to
the government carol malone liam thorpe
lovely to see we'll see you soon thank
you very much indeed